all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i'm a little i'm a little
worried here right the rumors are saying
that supposedly marvel studios is not
going to announce anything big at hall h
at san diego this year um that they're
going to announce a few things
but they're basically only going to
announce uh or they're going to announce
the big stuff like like black panther 2
wakanda forever all that kind of stuff
that's going to be a d23 check this out
y'all this is victor
yeah what's up what's good people how we
doing enjoying san diego
victor victor's legit he's got some
amazing comic book stories the problem
with love is i think my favorite one
yes i love the problem with love yeah
but he's also got kindergarten yes it's
an amazing story which you're like no no
this guy no let's let's tell the truth
about it no no no no we don't need to
worry about that
we will we will we will sleep we will
sleep out of the rock okay all right i
made victor's dream come true absolutely
we will leave it there but uh
but yeah man so
it was me and victor and like a couple
other guys yeah in the middle of the
night in the real rock you don't even
know yeah yeah
you know what we're gonna leave that
joke alone because that's gross okay so
here's the thing no no so the rumor have
you heard the rumors victor yes so the
rumors about marvel studios they're not
gonna do they're not gonna do black
panther two they're not gonna do
x like mutants not gonna do any of those
announcements in san diego right they're
gonna do it all in d23 right i don't
know if that's true and if it is there's
gonna be a lot of pissed off people in
hall age you're not wrong be a lot of
mad people in hall age yeah oh dude
we'll both people won't believe those
guys
like i don't even know where my staff is
man like i brought gordon caron like
tony landers all the social media stuff
i don't even know where these guys are
at they're they're enjoying the show
they're in holly's life actually you
know what here let me let me show you
let me show you guys what this looks
like so far and this is not a pack san
diego check this out
yeah so take a look at this take a look
at this
yeah
it's not even nuts it's just kind of
reasonable for the most part
so
there's victor but yeah
it's not even super powerful
but yeah just something to be aware of
guys that's the rumor i don't know if
it's true we won't know until we're in
hall h uh me and the guys actually we're
getting together with victor's group
we're all gonna camp out um because
apparently what what everybody's doing
like they're getting to hall h like like
in the morning like tonight
at like three o'clock in the morning and
they're gonna be there all day tomorrow
and they're going to be there all
through saturday night and then they're
going to get in there saturday morning
because the marvel studios panel is at
11 30 a.m so
fingers crossed they actually do have
the big announcement at uh in in holland
marvel studios but just something to
bear in mind there may be nothing coming
out from san diego comic-con this year
about wakanda forever or the mutants
like x-men fantastic four or anything
like that we'll just kind of have to
wait and see so anyway uh i'll catch you
guys later peace